der siebte kanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland erster chef einer rot grünen
bundesregierung
untrennbar mit seinem namen verbunden
die agenda 2010 deutsche soldaten die
erstmals seit 1945 wieder kämpfen im
kosovo in afghanistan nicht im irak
sein vorbild helmut schmidt der sohn
einer kriegerwitwe hat sich nach oben
gekämpft kannte als kind noch bittere
armut gerhard schröder
ein zeuge des jahrhunderts
in diesen tagen wurden sie 70 jahre alt
schön dass wir uns zu diesem anlass
unterhalten können
seit 2005 sind sie nicht mehr kanzler
wie ist es denn eigentlich wenn man
diese maximale machtposition hatte viel
einfluss prestige auch im ausland wie
lebt sich's denn dann in deutschland an
gewicht so schlecht muss ich sagen denn
ich hatte immer zwei traumberufen einer
war natürlich politisch zu arbeiten und
anschließend traum kanzler zu werden
der andere war immer rechtsanwalt und
das bin ich jetzt wieder das ist ganz
befriedigend aber man bleibt ein
politischer mensch das ja gar keine
frage und insofern interessiert mich
politik nach wie vor aber ohne druck und
ohne die notwendigkeit auf alles und
jedes zu reagieren aber ich habe gelesen
dass sie auch ein so einkaufen gehen
mozzarella katzenfutter und
schokopudding müssen sie besorgen und
wie reagiert man dann auf sie wenn sie
dort sind man kennt sich und insofern
gibt es bestimmte dinge die man halt tod
in der tat einkaufen gehört dazu das hat
schlicht damit zu tun dass meine frau da
jetzt politisch aktiv tätig ist und ich
mich nicht nur aber mit freude auch um
kinder kümmern gibt es ja hohe ansprüche
daran wie soll ein bundeskanzler ag sich
denn in der öffentlichkeit präsentieren
und mein eindruck ist dass die rolle
älter statement immer sanft immer
abwägend und freundlich zu allen dass
ihnen das irgendwie zu langweilig ist
die rolle
das ist gewiss eine richtige beobachtung
esels mal so sagen
der mainstream war nie das von mir
bevorzugte gewässer und insofern habe
ich das immer auf meine art gemacht und
das wird auch so bleiben
das heißt die wahrscheinlichkeit
gelegentlich anzuecken ist nicht
geringer geworden aber die konsequenzen
sind natürlich andere das für die partei
für die öffentlichkeit geht dann
meistens nur mich was die konsequenzen
angeht
damit habe ich gelernt zu leben also sie
polarisieren nach wie vor auch manchmal
gerne bringen die sachen auf den punkt
das jetzt krim krise
als sie sich das erste mal dazu geäußert
haben wladimir putin
sie haben eine gute beziehung zu ihm da
ging es um die frage war das
völkerrechts mäßig das eingreifen von
putin auf der kinder an sie formuliert
im korso habe ich damals auch das
völkerrecht gebrochen
damals gab es kein un-mandat sie wissen
natürlich genau wie unterschiedlich die
geschichten
natürlich weiß ich dass formal ist aber
das was ich gesagt habe richtig ebenso
wie das auch jetzt richtig ist und das
wollte ich zum ausdruck bringen zum
ausdruck bringen dass angesichts der
eigenen geschichte auch geschichte
anderer denken sie an den irak krieg
denken sie an der granada denken sie an
panama dass der erhobene zeigefinger
immer auch ein stück weit auf einen
selber zurück zeigt die anderen drei
nämlich die nicht erhoben sind das
wollte ich zum ausdruck bringen das
hatte nichts mit rechtfertigung zu tun
sondern nur mit 1 ordnung und dabei
bleibe ich auch und politisch hoffe ich
dass es gelingt wirklich gelingt dem
rahmen dessen was vorgeschlagen ist
äußerte da wirklich zu einer
vernünftigen lösung zu kommen ich
erwarte nicht dass es etwa im osten der
ukraine tendenzen gibt sich loszulösen
dass er auch fatal nach meiner meinung
so nicht erwartet dass wenn beide seiten
sich anstrengen ist zu einer
diplomatischen lösung kommt ich würde es
mir wünschen
ja mir ging es jetzt auch eher darum sie
haben eine gute beziehung zu verdingen
putin war bei ihrem sechzigsten
geburtstag haben die kosaken gesungen
und die balalaika ist gespielt
stecken sie was auch immer sie sagen zu
außenpolitik irgendwie in einer putin
falle
nein überhaupt nicht ich hoffe dass klar
wird dass das leder mit meiner
beruflichen tätigkeit zu tun hat noch
mit meinen mit der tatsache dass ich
zwei kinder aus russland adoptiert hat
ist total getrennt voneinander
meine beziehung zu russland ist übrigens
älter als die zu putin
die hat etwas mit history zu tun mit der
tatsache nämlich dass ich finde schon
die deutschen wir deutschen eine
besondere verantwortung haben angesichts
der tatsache dass aus nazi deutschland
heraus 5 und 3 25 millionen russen ihr
leben verloren haben die waren nicht
zuerst bei uns
sondern wir waren dort und deswegen
finde ich es auch sofort fatal wenn
irgendwelche vergleiche zwischen putin
einerseits und hitler andererseits
gemacht werden denn völlig übersehen
wird dass der mann und die familie
kinder verloren hat während der
deutschen besetzung oder des versuchs
der besetzung
man kann das in den historischen
zusammenhang stellen werden wir jetzt in
diesem jahr 100 jahre ausbruch erster
weltkrieg vor 75 jahren begann der
zweite weltkrieg und immer ging es auch
um interessen von staaten verschieben
von grenzen
viele bürger interessiert natürlich im
moment einfach die frage sehen sie eine
konkrete kriegsgefahr nein überhaupt
nicht
und die vergleiche die man mit 1914
anstellt sind wirklich nach meiner
auffassung grundfalsch jeder weiß dass
eine konfrontation zwischen russland auf
der einen seite und der nato auf der
anderen seite völlig ausgeschlossen ist
weil beide seiten ganz genau wissen was
das bedeuten würde
denn beide sind atomar gerüstete
jedenfalls teile dessen und von daher
glaube ich dass jeglicher vergleich mit
der situation von 1940 abwegig ist und
in die falsche richtung führt weil es
zur eskalation beiträgt und nicht zur
deeskalation
ich sehe überhaupt gar keine
kriegsgefahr trotzdem lernt man viel
daraus aus ihrem leben 1944 tobte der
totale krieg ihre mutter floh mit einer
freundin auf einen bauernhof im
westfälischen und an der ostfront fiel
ihr vater sechs monate nach dem sie
geboren war irgendwo prägt das auch das
leben des politikers schröder was er in
der jugend aufgenommen hat oder
interessanterweise weil ich meinen vater
nicht kannte hat mich das vielleicht
indirekt geprägt ohne ich das
wahrgenommen habe vaterlos aufzuwachsen
vielleicht hat das indirekt ohne ich das
wahrgenommen habe eine rolle gespielt
wir hatten eine sehr liebevolle mutter
meiner kindheit wie sicher bettelarm war
war aber keine unglückliche sondern ganz
im gegenteil eine wie ich sie jetzt auch
noch wahr nehme er glücklicher mann sehr
frei weil man nur da musste immer
arbeiten
und mussten uns sozusagen im dörflichen
leben selber zurecht finden hatten genug
zu essen und konnten für uns jungs
jedenfalls was das fußballspielen und
gerade zum mitkommen in der schule
das war in ordnung von daher als kinder
niemals geschlagen zu werden sondern mit
sehr viel mütterliche liebe bedacht zu
werden
das habe ich schon als im nachhinein als
ein auszeichnungen zu sein sie war ein
bisschen ausgegrenzt nicht das sagt das
ist wahr das ist im dörflichen leben so
nah war damals so und das beschäftigt
einen natürlichen das prägt auch wenn
sie sozusagen in einem familienkreis
aufwachsen mit dem bestimmte er nicht
spielen wieder so schön ist gesagt wird
dann trägt das möglicherweise dazu bei
dass es verhärtungen gibt die man auch
nie wieder los wird das ganz ein
wer hat ihnen eingetrichtert dass man
sich anstrengen muss wenn man es dann
schaffen will sie haben ja dann zu
lehrling waren die ausbildung gemacht
hatten die abendschule besucht und
mittlere reife und abitur zu machen wer
war denn derjenige oder diejenige die
gesagt hatte
das ist der weg es ist ja nicht ohne
anstrengung ja das ist richtig ich
glaube das weiß ich selbst ich wollte
daraus woher kam und mir war klar dass
das nur über den klassischen weg der
heißt bildung geht
und gott sei dank war die gesellschaft
offen genug auch das zu ermöglichen
offenheit meint dass man auch die
möglichkeit hatte als halbwaise der ich
war etwas später ein stipendium zu
bekommen ohne dass man eigenes geld das
er nicht da war einsetzen musste also
eine die offenheit einer gesellschaft
für soziale aufsteiger war schon etwas
was in den 50er 60er jahren mehr
geholfen hat gar keine frage und
letztlich wenn man mich fragt es war
wohl auch eigener ehrgeiz der da eine
rolle gespielt hat
also der feste wille auszukommen aus der
enge in der ich aufgewachsen
ich wollte immer anhalt werden das war
klar das war auch ihre entscheidung
nämlich an dass er das war
zurückzuführen auf fernsehserien des
damals gab es gab ein amerikanische
serie der serienheld his perry mason
und der konnte das so gut dass er fast
jeden aussichtslosen fall auch noch
gewann das mit meinem vorbild damals gar
keine frage es ist sowohl für ein guter
start
sie waren dann anwalt aber die politik
war dann gleich in ihrem leben drin und
1978 wurden sie vorsitzende der jusos
das ging schon ziemlich flott zur sache
damals waren sie weiter links als sie
heute sind das irgendwie zu seinem
lebenslauf dazu dass man in der jugend
einfach radikaler ist für dich das wäre
ja auch komisch wenn es anders wäre man
beschäftigt sich doch sehr viel mehr mit
dem was gut und richtig ist als dem was
möglich ist und ich verlege der immer zu
sagen später als ministerin und ganzen
habe ich dann die revolution verhindert
die ich früher selber geplant habe
das war so gleichwohl das war ja in der
sogenannten 68er zeit ein richtiger 68
obwohl ich glaube dass die
achtundsechziger bewegung viel für die
offenheit deutschlands getan hat ein
richtiger 68er kunde ich deshalb nicht
mehr werden weil ich studium als ein
ungeheures privileg begriffen habe ich
war zum ersten mal wirklich frei in dem
sinne dass ich selber entscheiden konnte
sie sind also leute andere themen ja ich
hatte andere themen und für mich war zum
beispiel keine enge im elternhaus und
keine revolte gegenüber einem elternhaus
das etwa in der nazizeit schuldhaft
gehandelt hatte bei mir war auch keine
totale abwehr gegen eine gesellschaft in
der es mega immerhin ermöglicht wurde
diesen sozialen aufstieg auch zu
beginnen in etwa dieser zeit viele auch
diese anekdote die kann ich ihnen nicht
ersparen dass sie nach einem
feuchtfröhlichen abend im kanzleramt
gerüttelt gesagt haben sie wollten da
rein
dahinter steckt ja irgendwo braucht man
doch ein grund ehrgeiz um diesen weg
einschlagen zu wollen hatten sie damals
schon in sich
keine frage ich war damals junger
abgeordneter und wir hatten eine kneipe
gegenüber dem kanzleramt auf der anderen
straßenseite dieses provinz
merkwürdigerweise da trafen sich dann
die ersten grünen und die jungen
sozialdemokraten der linken
sozialdemokraten und in der tat nach
einem feuchtfröhlichen abend war das so
das da rein wollte das kann ich
bestätigen nicht bestätigen kann ich
dass es irgendeinen zeitpunkt gegeben
aber ich wo ich von innen wo auch immer
gerüttelt habe und gesagt habe ich will
da raus also 2005 war nicht freiwillig
gutes haben wir jetzt markiert
sie waren in den 80ern abgeordnete im
deutschen bundestag da ging es auch um
nachrüstung zum beispiel eines der
großen themen helmut schmidt war
bundeskanzler und sie der kritische
junge abgeordnete hatten damit nichts am
hut mit der nachrüstung der nachrüstung
nichts und ich musste später einsehen
dass er wohl mehr recht habe ich mir
auch gesagt als ich zur damaligen zeit
denn der doppelbeschluss den er gemacht
hat gegen den wir resultierten hat
möglicherweise in der tat dazu geführt
dass letztlich die ss 20 raketen dann
auch beseitigt werden konnten
also insofern muss ich und wie gesagt
ich habe ihm dasselbe gesagt auch sagen
also im nachhinein eine historische
wahrnehmen war wohl wichtiger als meine
aber man kann auch bei ihnen und auch
bei helmut schmidt sehen
sozialdemokratische bundeskanzler habe
es mit der eigenen vater eigentlich nie
leicht das ist richtig weil die spd will
die welt immer besser machen und zwar
auch die welt die sich schon gut gemacht
hat das ist einer der beweggründe über
den baum ich da drin bin auch immer da
drin bleiben werde
und insofern den ärger den ich anderen
gemacht hatte in meiner zeit als junger
abgeordneter oder gar den
jungsozialisten habe ich später selber
zu spüren gekriegt das ist ein stück
historische gerechtigkeit der nächste
große einschnitte eigentlich in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik war die
wende
eigentlich der fall der mauer und das
hat sie und andere erstmal bei der spd
es war eine verbreitete meinung auf dem
falschen fuß auf dem linken
wie kann das eigentlich wie kam diese
ablehnung dass man gar nicht mehr daran
glaubt es könnte man irgendwann eine
wiedervereinigung geben
wir haben in anderen kategorien gedacht
wir haben sozusagen in der kategorie
frieden absolut gesetzt und gedacht und
sagen und immer geglaubt dass die
friedliche entwicklung das wichtigste
überhaupt ist und an den zusammenbruch
dessen was man den weltkommunismus
nennen könnte eher weniger gar nicht so
sehr weil man mit der sehr orthodoxen
art wie das lammert vonstattengehen
einverstanden war das nicht unser punkt
sondern wie gesagt die die absolut
setzung der friedlichen entwicklung hat
dann dazu geführt dass wahrnehmungen die
sich andeuteten in polen im vorher schon
in der tschechoslowakei die damals noch
existierte nicht von uns nicht so
wahrgenommen wurden wieder in der
generation die das einheitliche
deutschland noch kannte insofern war das
eine historische schwieriger und sicher
auch falsche wahrnehmung keine fragen
und vor diesem hintergrund wie sie so
leute meine mode kohl hatte es da hat in
kürze und endlich zu gehen hat diese
situation genutzt sondern gemacht gar
keine frage soll ich sie fragen ja er
hat das gut gemacht das wird auch seine
große historische leistung bleiben und
zwar gut gemacht in dem sinne dass er
das vertrauen wenn ich mal vielleicht
von frau thatcher absehe
in der in der nato in der eu hatte
insbesondere der vertrauen der
amerikaner hatte dass das bei ihm dieses
neue größere deutschland schon richtig
aufgehoben sei
damit dieser sehr unterstützt worden in
der name insight von willy brandt ja
bekanntlicherweise und von anderen in
unserer partei und insofern aber seine
historische leistung die bleibt bestehen
und wie zu mildern ist auch nicht meine
sache
die ära kohl bekam quasi eine zweite
halbzeit eigentlich sind ja das haben
sie selbst mal gesagt kannst du nach
acht jahren schon ziemlich durch die
öffentlichkeit
zermürbt worden auch die diese ständige
präsenz die sie haben müssen eher becker
haben sie die zweite halbzeit
und in der zeit sagten viele dachten
viele die endet nie diese am ende 16
jahre
wann hatten sie gern schuhe das erste
mal das gefühl dass sie es sein könnten
der ihn ablöst irgendwann irgendwo wenn
alles gut läuft im hinterkopf hat man
das natürlich immer für möglich und für
wünschbar gehalten ist gar keine frage
ich war damals der ministerpräsident und
als solcher relativ erfolgreich erst mit
einer rot grünen koalition später auch
an mit einer absoluten mehrheit
rechnet man wird man automatisch zu
einem denkbaren kandidaten gerechnet
zumal dann wenn man sich selber dazu
rechnet und das war so in meinem fall
ich glaube dass das die die möglichkeit
in der wahl 98 zu gewinnen sich
herausstellte in 97 vor allen dingen als
um die frage ging wer hätte denn er
möglichkeiten zu gewinnen gegen herrn
kohl lafontaine oder ich und als wir
eine diskussion hatten über die frage
wofür steht der eine wofür steht der
andere
ich habe es immer für wichtig und
richtig gehalten dass die spd eine wahl
nur dann gewinnen kann wenn auch ein
eine ein maß an
zureichende ökonomische kompetenz da ist
und man in deutschland schwer eine eine
wahl kontrovers zur wirtschaft gewinnen
kann denn es gibt eine alte erfahrung
der parteien der arbeiterbewegung der
gewerkschaften und die heißt ganz
schlicht wenn es der wirtschaft
insgesamt gut geht haben wir bessere
möglichkeiten etwas davon abzubekommen
wenn krise ist ist die gefahr relativ
groß dass die krise bewältigt wird oft
lasten zulasten der schwächsten und das
führt dann eben auch dazu dass in einer
solchen situation ist schwieriger ist
für die beschäftigten verlangen durch
partei und gewerkschaften diese diese
historische erfahrung in der
arbeiterbewegung die hat jedenfalls in
meinem denken dazu geführt zu sagen
ökonomische kompetenz ist das was unsere
eigenen leute von uns erwarten und eine
total konfrontation mit der wirtschaft
macht keinen sinn
aber das ist die rad zuerst haben sie
sicherlich recht
aber dass politik besteht ja auch aus
persönlichen interessen die es da gibt
und in den neunzigern sie waren sprecher
der spd auch für wirtschaftsfragen sind
da oft angeeckt hatten viel ärger
deswegen aber oskar lafontaine war ja
eigentlich der mann der partei in der
sauna der wahl fest verankert war das
der grund dass sie das sehr kühnes
gemacht haben bei der wahl landtagswahl
in niedersachsen 98 haben sie gesagt
will ich nicht auf das sehr hohe
ergebnis noch was drauflegen dann bin
ich eigentlich nicht der kanzler kann er
hat während das war klar
ja natürlich es ging ja auch nicht
anders denn dass oskar lafontaine wenn
das in vorstand entschieden worden wäre
als zwei drittel mehrheit gehabt hätte
das gar keine frage
ich hab das war mit ihm besprochen kurz
vor der niedersachsenwahl haben wir uns
in braunschweig ich erinnere das
ziemlich genau getroffen und ich habe
ihm damals vorgeschlagen
wenn ich das gleiche ergebnis waren über
42 in niedersachsen bekommen wie beim
letzten mal dann werde ich kandidat mit
einer zustimmung und hatte mich das
machen wir nicht
du musst schon mehr kriegen und dann wie
viel das ich der summe 45 prozent sonst
muss das der parteivorstand entscheiden
prägte dann glaube ich 848 und dann war
es für ihn auch klar weil er hat das
dann akzeptiert und gesagt okay
möglicherweise es wirklich so dass mit
ihm an der spitze wir bessere chancen
haben
und lafontaine zu dem damaligen
zeitpunkt ihm war persönlicher ehrgeiz
weniger wichtig den hat er durchaus auch
wenn es gelegentlich anders dargestellt
hat als der sieg der spd und dann hat er
im grunde dieser entscheidung mit
herbeigeführt dann wurden sie kannst du
ein kandidat der wahlkampf begann
es war sicherlich rot grün eine eine
kühne vision damals nach so vielen
jahren kanzler helmut kohl mit der
schwarz-gelben koalition und 27
september 98 war es dann soweit
wann nach der ersten hochrechnung hatten
sie das gefühl jetzt ist es soweit schon
vorher
es war relativ klar in den umfragen in
ihren wie in denen der anderen auch das
dass es wohl nicht reichen würde dass es
so deutlich werden
bei uns nicht klar aber es hat auch ein
bisschen daran gelegen dass wir einen
fehler nicht gemacht haben nämlich den
fehler helmut kohl sozusagen direkt
anzugreifen wir haben das war meine
vorstellung einen wahlkampf geführt nach
dem muster danke helmut jetzt ist aber
auch genug aber es ging auch gleich hoch
her 99 war in die awo hatte jede woche
irgendwas passiert rot grün da dachte
man an friedenspolitik und dann die
balkan krise die schon lange gingen sie
spitzte sich zu in dem kosovo konflikt
und das erste mal mussten sie als
bundeskanzler dann soldaten einsetzen im
krieg wie ist eine solche entscheidung
wieder legt man die ist das über mehrere
wochen eine vorbereitung diskussion mit
allen beteiligten und wer fällt dann am
ende die entscheidung irgendwann war
klar dass es wohl nicht ging ohne ohne
auch einsatz von militärischer gewalt
und das ist letztlich eine entscheidung
die sie vorbereitet durch und
abgesprochen mit verteidigungs und
außenminister letztlich selber treffen
müssen und das ist deswegen eine so
unglaublich schwierige entscheidung
jedenfalls war das so für mich gar nicht
so sehr aus ich war nie pazifist in dem
sinne gar nicht so sehr aus diesen
pazifistischen erwägungen die mir auch
näher sind als interventionen aber vor
allen dingen weil ich mich immer gefragt
habe kannst du das verantworten
gegenüber den leuten die du dahin
schicken
denn die tragen greife haut zu markte
nicht du der die entscheidung triffst
und deswegen ist es unglaublich einfach
es ist politisch kompliziert aber
psychisch sehr einfach nein zu sagen
aber sehr schwer jahr zusagen aus dem
eben die kennzeichen grund das hat mich
richtig schlaflose nächte im wahrsten
sinne des wortes gekostet letztlich
überwog dann doch die einsicht in die
notwendigkeit dieser freiheit sein soll
die einsicht in die notwendigkeit dass
es nicht anders ging auch und gerade aus
mündlichen bündnis politischen
gesichtspunkten
denn eines war klar die rot-grüne neue
bundesregierung war ein besonderer weise
unter beobachtung keineswegs nur bei den
in jugoslawien sondern vor allen dingen
innerhalb der nato was würden sie tun
kann man mit denen als stabiler
bündnispartner nur rechnen oder fallen
die völlig aus das war eine erwägung die
natürlich auch eine rolle gespielt hat
und spielen mussten ja und gerade
derzeit hatten sie ja schon einiges
einzustecken oskar lafontaine war in
diesem umfeld zurückgetreten
von allen ämtern also finanzminister hat
sein bundestagsmandat und den
parteivorsitz niedergelegt ich kann mir
vorstellen das ist dann auch stress muss
hat sie das tatsächlich ich habe in
allen quellen guckt offenkundig wirklich
überraschen völlig überraschend völlig
überraschend
es kam ein boot zu mir ich weiß noch
genau dass in bonn im kanzleramt mit
einem verschlossenen brief vom damaligen
finanzminister und parteivorsitzenden
und erzählen wir den brief überreicht
ich weiß gar nicht wer das da war mir
natürlich klar ist nicht ein
geburtstagsgruß drin sondern dann muss
schon das ernst zu sein und ich machte
ihn dann auf und klickt dann die
mitteilung dass er von seinem von seinem
amt als finanzminister zurück tritt das
war ja das was er den bundeskanzler zu
sagen hatte aber dann auch
aufgeschrieben dass er aus dem bundestag
ausscheidet und sein amt auch als
parteivorsitzender niederlegt ich war
sehr überrascht war auf völlig
unvorbereitet ich weiß noch genau
fischer kam in jogging kleidung
angeblich anschließend weil ich ihn
anrufe fitness phase 3 er hat die
fitness phase wieder mal kam in jogging
kleidung ins kanzleramt und die anderen
beraten was zu tun sei und es sehr
interessant ich war nicht sicher ob ich
den parteivorsitz übernehmen sollte das
erste was fischer sagt du musst das
machen
es war in der damaligen situation wohl
auch der richtige rad andere wie
müntefering und zu haben das dann auch
gesagt und das war natürlich für die spd
noch entscheidender aber ich war
wirklich überrascht und ich habe bis
heute keine wirklich schlüssige
erklärung dafür außer derjenigen dass er
jemand war der mit den widrigkeiten
eines solchen amtes der auch darin
bestehen dinge zu tun die einem nicht
gut gefallen und die der eigenen
klientel nicht gut gefallen die auch mal
gegen den konsens der eigenen partei
verstoßen müssen nicht als dauerzustand
aber gelegentlich schon nicht
zurechtgekommen ist die begründung
sozialabbau und und der krieg dann
finden sie deswegen auch holz als er
nach geschoben
der krieg daran war an der vorbereitung
del dieser diskussion mit der
entscheidung beteiligt die ging er noch
als kohle noch im amt was für eine große
moralische diskussion in der natürlich
aber das glaube ich ist dann auch
rationalisierung wenn um es freundlich
zu sagen für ihn weil ich hab das nie
verstanden war wirklich einer der
begabtesten politiker ist die ich
kennengelernt ist ein bisschen die
flucht aus verantwortung wenn sie
unangenehm ist über das verhältnis zu
ihm zu ihnen gesprochen
einmal habe ich gesagt was willst du
eigentlich und seine antwort war ich
will die macht und die kohle also sehr
ihre antwort gewesen die macht und die
kohle so war der das ist ja auch was ich
an ihm geschätzt aber er fühlte sich
also da nicht so weit entfernt finden
sie das als der favorit oder was er
macht ist das richtig dass andere hat
mich nicht so sehr interessiert wie er
da unterstellt ich glaube da er eigenes
verhalten in die in die antwort
hineingelegt aber wie auch immer dass
ich an demokratisch legitimiert er macht
interessiert war an politische an
politischer macht umgestalten zu können
das zu bestreiten da ja widersinnig denn
das kennzeichnet ja mein politisches
leben ja geld zu verdienen ist ja auch
nun kann und das ist in ordnung aber wie
gesagt dass ich hätte ja und anderen
lebensweg einschlagen können vielleicht
auch nicht ohne erfolg aber das hat mich
in erster linie nicht interessiert
sondern mehr die möglichkeit in der
politik das zu erreichen was ich
erreicht habe war für meinen lebensweg
bei weitem bedeutender als
geld zu verdienen das ist in der tat
nicht schlecht tue ich jetzt ja auch und
schafft ein stück neuer freiheit die ich
durchaus auch in ordnung finde aber das
waren turbulenzen eine nach der anderen
im grunde hat man da als bundeskanzler
mal das gefühl jetzt reicht's auch erst
das mehrertrag ich nicht ein ich hab
mich das natürlich gefragt ob aber das
männchen sinn gekommen vielleicht ist
das auch etwas was man braucht
dass in einem solchen amt das ja schon
sehr sehr anstrengend ist und sehr
einsam macht auch vielleicht ist es das
auch aber hinzuwerfen
auf diese idee in keiner phase gab er
wirklich schwierige sie haben darüber
berichtet er in keiner phase bin ich
darauf gekommen werden es kam danach zum
nächsten punkt auch dass wieder eine
herausforderung der elfte september 2001
der terroranschlag auf das world trade
center mit den passagierflug zahlen
zeugen sicherlich für jeden einen
einschnitt in der zeit sie haben da
unglaublich schnell reagiert und die
uneingeschränkte solidarität erklärt
damals war george tabori busch der
präsident der vereinigten staaten
sowas macht man doch nicht ohne zu ahnen
dass das was bedeutet wenn man das sagt
natürlich wusste ich dass ich das eher
dass das bedeutet was bedeutet und ich
wusste auch dass es bedeuten könnte in
afghanistan zusammen mit den amerikanern
zu intervenieren
das war das was klar wir klar war er
weil so war dass die terroristen die in
new york und pentagon tätig gewesen
geworden waren dort ihre bomben ihre
flugzeug angriffe gemacht hatten dass
die eben schutz fanden und es war völlig
klar dass wir reagieren würden und zwar
an der seite der amerikaner und das war
eine frage des artikel 5 des nato
vertrags
es war keine frage dass es eine
legitimation durch den sicherheitsrat
gab mit zustimmung ging nicht anders der
chinesen und der russin und von daher
war diese entscheidung zwangsläufig und
war nicht die schwierigste die sie
treffen
die war nicht das war nicht die
schwierigste
scheidung natürlich was dann auch wieder
schwer unter dem gesichtspunkt 'nicht
eingangs gesagt hat bei entscheidungen
für kriegerische interventionen immer an
die leute zu denken die man dahin
schickt aber hier war völlig
unausweichlich dass wir an der seite der
amerikaner sein würden und ich musste
das denn wir durchsetzen mit der
vertrauensfrage was nicht so einfach war
aber was dann gelangt und deswegen habe
ich auch manchmal
na ja so ein bisschen ein bisschen
traurig darüber nachgedacht warum das
eigentlich nie gewürdigt worden ist auch
in den vereinigten staaten dass eine
rot-grüne regierung war die sofort
gesagt hat wir sind an der seite unserer
freunde willkommen so innenpolitik
zurück dann standen auch schon wieder
bundestagswahlen 2002 beschreiben sie
doch mal die situation die man sich
heute gar nicht so vorstellen kann wie
die wirtschaftliche lage war seine hohe
arbeitslosigkeit die rentenkassen waren
leer und die ökonomie bestimmt oft die
wahlen wie viele schon gesagt haben es
war schwer
ungewöhnlich schwierig und wir mussten
noch damit rechnen dass das sie war
verloren gehen würde weil gründe dafür
haben sie genannt
und es ist ja so auch wenn wenn die
politik über die einstellungen und
entlassungen in der privaten wirtschaft
nicht entscheidet das wird eher
zugewiesen die verantwortung dafür von
vielen und deswegen was eine
schwierigkeit es kam in der damaligen
zeit waren dann zwei entscheidungen von
bedeutung einmal waren wir nicht
überzeugt von der amerikanischen
intervention im irak und haben das auch
deutlich gemacht aber noch
entscheidender glaube ich jedenfalls war
diese frage wie werden die mit dieser
flut die damals kam eben sommer 2002
fertig und das ist ja eine zeit wo
regierung dem volk beweisen kann
das ist was taugt das die da sind und
das heißt taugen tut man dann was wenn
man unmittelbar präsent ist und hilft
und ich glaube dass das war entscheidend
dass die menschen gesehen haben wir
können uns auf die verlassen wahlkampfes
ihre große zeit
das ist eine besondere herausforderung
und auch ein besondere herne besondere
intensität von leben und von politischem
leben natürlich insofern wenn sie zu
spüren dass sie das die menschen
mitgehen dann ist das schon eine
herausforderung einerseits aber auch
eine ungeheure bestätigung und gerade in
dem wald kam wo wir alle schon ein
bisschen glaubt na ja das was denn wohl
kam dann zum schluss waren das die
wahlveranstaltungen die draußen von
stahl stattfand mit zehn 20.000 menschen
eher gelesene messen als
wahlkampfveranstaltungen ich hab da
manche einen gefragt ist das so weil die
einen noch mal sehen wollen ehemann
abtritt oder oder ist das wirklich
zustimmen täglich zustimmung
sie haben die wahl dann gewonnen 2002
und da reifte was in ihnen das
innenpolitisch was passieren musste in
der wirtschaft sie haben da ein projekte
angepackt von dem sie sicherlich von
anfang an wussten dass gibt vollständig
ärger auf allen mit den gewerkschaften
mit der eigenen partei aber auch
insgesamt diskussionen die agenda 2010
die damals noch nicht so hieß das war
ein erster vor überlegungen
verraten sie uns was hat sie tatsächlich
dazu gebracht und es wird ihn doch klar
gewesen sein was sie auslösen denn es
war so für uns wurde immer deutlicher
dass die deutsche wirtschaft in über
große schwierigkeiten kommen würden die
arbeitslosenzahlen wuchsen und uns war
klar es musste etwas geschehen wir
hatten die gutachten des
sachverständigenrates ich war damals von
bert rürup auch persönlich beraten in
diese richtung etwas zu tun
steinmeier war damals chef des
kanzleramts hatte eben solche positionen
und ich habe das mit müntefering
besprochen und anderen und wir sind dann
zu überzeugen gekommen wenn wir jetzt
nicht handeln dann wird diese
entwicklung weiter gehen und dann werden
wir von der entwicklung weggespült
werden
also wenn wir nicht reformieren wird ein
wildgewordener markt uns reformieren und
wir werden die leidtragenden sein also
war diese entscheidung relativ rasch
klar dass etwas passieren musste und es
kam etwas anderes hinzu wir hatten ja
lange versucht im bündnis für arbeit
also im konsens zwischen regierung
gewerkschaften und arbeitgeberverbänden
eine solche reform agenda hinzubekommen
etwa nach dem holländischen muster und
das hielt sie hat sich in deutschland
als nicht durchsetzbar erwiesen weil die
beiden die gewerkschaften einerseits und
die arbeitgeberverbände anders als die
regierung immer du benutzen wollten zur
durchsetzung ihrer spezifischen
forderungen aber sich außer stande sein
aufeinander zuzugehen
wir wollten das ja managen also als dass
sich herausstellte nicht erreichbar zu
sein haben wir müssen das jetzt eben
machen und eine erfahrung die ich da
gemacht habe die müssen sich andere auch
vor augen führen
die nämlich dass man solche
anspruchsvollen reformen vermutlich nur
durchsetzen kann top down und niemals
bottom up warum wenn man wenn man
versucht konsens vorher zu finden wird
das programm zur rede die gefahr besteht
nämlich durch interessengruppen auch in
den parteien in den koalitionsparteien
und dann wird es nicht mehr das sein was
notwendig ist wenn man indessen versucht
mit der kraft der regierung und auch mit
der drohung sonst geht das schief etwas
durchzusetzen was an sich hand und fuß
hat dann ist das in unseren sehr
pluralen gesellschaften wahrscheinlich
eher ein erfolgsrezept als das
umgekehrte ist ja gelegentlich
vorgeworfen worden man hätte das breite
diskutieren müssen
das mag idealtypisch und der demokratie
theoretischen gesichtspunkten auch für
sein in der sache hätte es dazu geführt
dass die agenda so nicht zustande
gekommen wenn man muss das mal wörtlich
zitieren was sie damals gesagt haben wir
werden leistungen des staates kürzen
eigenverantwortung fördern und mehr
eigenleistung von jedem einzelnen
abfordern
erst war schon haben sicher nur ich
halte das jahr für sozialdemokrat
hab ich immer gehalten das hat
vielleicht etwas mit meinem lebensweg zu
tun schauen sie jeder soll das was er
kann auch beitragen für sich selbst für
seine familie auch für die gesellschaft
nur das was er kann
wenn er nicht kann weil er bildungsmäßig
nicht mitgekommen ist weil er krank ist
weil er arbeitslos ist aus welchen weil
er alt oder zu jung ist dann muss der
staat für der für die gesellschaft
handelt einspringen aber das darf nicht
dazu führen dass man von jemanden etwas
fordert sondern die eben mögliche oder
ihr mögliche leistung muss erbringen
wollen auch sonst muss man ihn dazu
anhalten oder sie dazu anhalten wenn man
es in der rückschau sieht dann muss man
sagen es ist so schade dass die spd sich
zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt und später
auch nicht in der lage gesehen hat
dieses doch wichtige reformprogramm
nicht nur für deutschland für europa als
ihr eigenes anzunehmen und entsprechend
zu vertreten
es gab abgeordneten die dann in den
wahlkreis gehalten dass sie alles für
für zweifelhaft oder schröder hat uns
gezwungen das ist dann eine haltung die
natürlich in wahlen auch nicht auch
nicht honoriert werden hatten sie damit
gerechnet dass es bis zur nächsten wahl
2006 erfolge gibt ich hatte das gehofft
natürlich aber als klar war dass wir die
nordrhein westfalen wahl verloren hatten
war mir auch klar du wirst ohne ein
neues mandat nicht zurechtkommen und die
entscheidende überlegung für mich war
die kritik an der agenda weil auf dem
höhepunkt die innerparteiliche in der
gewerkschaftliche kritik und die der
wahlverlust in nordrhein westfalen wurde
sozusagen benutzt auch in der
öffentlichen diskussion zur
rechtfertigung der kritik an der agenda
das war ja ein zusammenhang und meine
überlegung die dann zu der neuen
entscheidung führte war zu sagen es geht
eigentlich nur weiter mit einem neuen
mandat des volkes und deswegen habe ich
gesagt wir müssen in neuwahlen rein ich
habe das damals mit franz müntefering
sehr intensiv besprochen hat
ihn gefragt kannst du garantieren dass
bis 2006 übernehmen jahr 2005 im mai
2005 feier die nrw-wahl kannst du
garantieren bis zum ordentlichen ende
der legislaturperiode dass die fraktion
steht oder wird ziemlich angesichts der
niederlage jetzt der möglichen
schwierigkeiten die wir in rheinland
pfalz in 2006 im februar kriegen würden
wird sie mich zwingen die agenda zu
verändern und dass die agentur hätte ich
nicht verändert und dann sagte mir herr
müntefering
das kann ich nicht garantieren und da
war für mich klar und ich glaube
letztlich für ihn auch dass wir
versuchen mussten aus dieser enger
manche sagten builders kabinett um was
man so macht aber das war nicht die lage
dann mussten versuchen rauszukommen
indem wir sagten wir wollen eine neue
legitimation auch für die agenda 2010
durchs volk durch die wählerinnen und
wähler nur noch mal für die zuschauer zu
markieren vor allem für die jüngeren die
wunden die landtagswahl in nrw ging
verloren krachend verloren in dem
stammland der sozialdemokratie und das
hat sie dann einfach dazu gebracht jetzt
reicht's jetzt brauche ich die wähler
das war nicht so einfach ist verfassungs
sieht das nicht so einfach vor
schwierige zeit auch für ein
persönliches dass man sagen weil der dem
moment wo ich in der hand anderer waren
wo ich sozusagen nicht mehr nicht mehr
die kontrolle hatte über das tun denn
jetzt musste zunächst einmal die
koalition sagen in der tat wir bestimmen
sozusagen bei dem misstrauensvotum gegen
unsere eigene regierung
dann müsste der bundespräsident das
akzeptieren und schließlich das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch das
funktioniert funktioniert aber das war
eine eine der schwierigsten situation
überhaupt verstehen sie einfach wenn sie
in einer solchen situation sind und
sagen weiter geht es eigentlich nur mit
einer legitimation durch das volk und
sie sind in dreifacher abhängigkeit
das möchte ich nie wieder erleben
gott versuchen wir eine bilanz ihrer
regierungszeit joschka fischer
geschrieben hat dass überschrieben hat
dann gern englisch gesprochen facing
reality sie haben sich also der
wirklichkeit gestellt und wirklich
reformen versucht würden sie sich auch
so sehen als modernisierer das schon das
will ich sehen und zwar scheiterte
momentane durch dieses war wenn man sich
jetzt die diskussion in europa anschaut
kann man nicht sagen dass man das gefühl
haben müsste die agenda seien
gescheitert das projekt das hingegen die
ernte kam nach ihrer tat aber es ist in
der tat und frage von scheitern oder
nicht scheitern heißt ja nicht aufhören
oder nicht aufhören der regierungszeit
sondern heißt welche wirkungen hat das
in die gesellschaft für das land hinein
und die waren durchweg durchweg positiv
bei all dem was zu kritisieren ist gar
keine freie skater noch etwas was man
mindestens ebenso wichtig ist nicht so
sehr die souveränität in der
außenpolitik das auch aber vor allen
dingen auch die veränderung im
gesellschaftlichen klima es ist doch
interessant dass in der zeit der
grundstein dafür gelegt wurden das heute
zwischen cdu und spd ist keinen großen
unterschied mehr gibt in der frage
integration der menschen mit
ausländischem hintergrund sondern das
nach jahre jahrzehntelangen kämpfen über
diese frage inzwischen gemeinsamkeit
besteht in dieser an in der
notwendigkeit integration ernst zu
nehmen und das zweite ist was ich auch
finde dass wir es erreicht haben in
unserer zeit die diskussion über die
diskriminierung von
gleichgeschlechtlichen
lebensgemeinschaften zu verändern und
positiv zu gestalten hat diese
gesellschaft freier offener gemacht und
ich hoffe dass das auch auswirkungen auf
andere gesellschaften hat wir sind da
ziemlich gut
also es hat sich einiges verändert in
der zeit das wall street journal hat es
ja dann sehr gelobt für für diese erhält
dafür eine freut weil ich das nie
erwartet habe und mein eindruck ist aber
auch vor merkel hat sie dafür gelobt
mehrfach im bundestag aber nach wie vor
fremdelt ihre partei
ich sage das hat damit zu tun dass sie
diese vorstellung die ich versucht habe
zu erläutern von von sozialdemokrat sein
heißt nicht betreut zu werden sondern
heißt hilfe zu bekommen aus sich selbst
las zu machen
das ist das was für mich wichtig ist
heißt dafür zu sorgen dass die
gesellschaft offen genug bleibt um
menschen aus die nicht mit dem goldenen
löffel im mund geboren worden sind
eine chance in dieser gesellschaft zu
gehen dass alles für mich ist
sozialdemokratie dass es gelegentlich
auch notwendig gibt menschen betreuung
zu geben dass er gar keine frage
nur betreuung ist das karitative hilfe
zur selbsthilfe ist etwas was würde
verleiht
wir haben angefangen unsere gespräch wie
fühlen sie sich jetzt als kanzler damals
als sie aufhörte sicher läge ein
einschnitt auch im alltag sind sie recht
schnell in eine beraterfunktion bei
nordstream einer pipeline die auch von
mehrheitlich von gazprom beherrscht wird
also bleibt mir putin hat er sicherlich
seinen einfluss eingebracht dafür sind
sie oft kritisieren haben dafür würden
sie sagen dass sie zu früh einen wechsel
in die wirtschaft noch immer in die
kritik wäre ja auch gekommen
ein halbes jahr gewartet oder ein jahr
gewartet wenn ich stelle mir manchmal
die frage wenn diese gesellschaft eine
wäre wo anstatt eines russischen
unternehmens partner der europäisches
ein europäisches konsortium ein
amerikanisches wäre wie dann wohl die
kritik ausgefallen wäre ich glaube da
spielen immer dinge noch eine rolle die
meinen licht sind für mich war einst
völlig klar ich war nicht in einer
situation wo ich sozusagen ein rentner
leben führen wollte und konnte sich auch
nicht gekonnt sondern für mich war
wichtig etwas zu tun zu bekommen und das
natürlich an der grenze zwischen
juristischer beratung die mein beruf ist
und politik und das habe ich versucht zu
realisieren
es ist schließlich mein leben
ich habe das getan was ich für richtig
und notwendig hielten in der politik
habe dafür auch risiken in kauf genommen
und ich finde dass man danach
währenddessen wird hat es nie vorwürfe
für mich gegeben und an mich gegeben
weder in meiner zeit als abgeordneter
noch in meiner zeit als ministerin einer
zeit als bundeskanzler
danach habe ich ein recht das zu tun was
ich für richtig halte
und dazu stehen sie auch zu stehen zu
ihren siebzigsten haben sie jetzt das
recht zu sagen welchen politischen
wunsch sie erfüllt haben möchten für die
zukunft wenn wir zahlreiche themen
angesprochen in diesem spiel
ich komme zurück auf das was ich zuletzt
gesagt habe ich möchte gern noch mit
dafür dazu beitragen dass diese
gesellschaft so offen bleibt das soziale
aufstieg auch für die kinder aus
familien die es nicht so dicke haben
möglich bleibt dass wir nicht wieder
fragen welche gute schule hast du
besorgen besucht und welche beste
universität sondern was kannst du was
bist du zu leisten bereit und imstande
für mich ist es einfach so dass in jeder
gesellschaft brauche reports eliten ich
habe keine schwierigkeit mit diesem
begriff umzugehen obwohl er
missverstanden werden kann
aber für mich müssen dass eliten seien
niemals qua geburt immer nur leistung
und dazu beizutragen und die offenheit
und die offenheit zu gewährleisten
die es immer noch möglich macht
lebenswege wie man eigenen als
selbstverständlich anzusehen
das war ein wunsch könig hätte und ein
bisschen mitarbeiten will den wunsch
nehmen wir auf gerhard schröder zum
siebzigsten
vielen dank für dieses gespräch und eine
gute zeit noch vielen dank